[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEFAN HAUK: We use the Google
platform because it allows us
to focus on the things we want
to do, which is delight our
fans with good games.
I'm Stefan Hauk.
I'm Lead Server Developer
at Rovio Entertainment.
We make the "Angry Birds"
and "Bad Piggies" games.
We really appreciate the instant
scalability, because
when we release a new game, it
usually becomes immediately
very popular.
We have 263 million monthly
players, at the end of last
year, who are already
playing our games.
And when we tell them that
there's a new game, they all
come to it and try to play it.
So we need a lot of computer
power from the start.
OLIVER MICHON: So we are making
some more games, but
our latest one is called "Song
Pop." It's a music game on
Android, iOS, on the web.
We're using Google Cloud because
it helps us go fast
from a quick prototype in a few
months to scaling to tens
of millions of users.
We can go effortlessly from 10
users to 80 million users.
I think Google Cloud platform
help us reach our 80 million
users with a very small team.
And it's not something we could
have done anywhere else.
ALAGAPPAN ALS: I'm Alagappan.
I'm a backend engineer
at Pocket Gems.
We're building a mobile
entertainment company, and our
focus is to build innovative
products that push the
envelope in this industry.
Google App Engine is definitely
a critical part of
our technical stack.
And we use the data that we
collect from App Engine to
develop interesting, exciting
features and make our games
more interesting.
We chose Google App Engine
because we wanted to focus on
developing features that are
facing millions of users,
rather than having to
focus on hardware.
STEFAN HAUK: My advice would be
that you should try to keep
your team small, focus on what
you can do best, and leave the
operational aspects
to the people who
know how to do that--
in that case, the Google
Cloud Platform team.
The most important thing that
we want to achieve is to
delight our fans with great
games and good products.
And the Google Cloud platform
allows us to focus just on
that and leave the other
parts aside.
[MUSIC PLAYING]